- Yeah, I'm hanging with Rainn
Wilson on Skype, give it up!
(audience cheering and applause)
You know my next guest
from "Days of Our Lives,"
"Melrose Place" and "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills."
Since then she's become
a successful entrepreneur
whose beauty line launches November 30th.
It's called Renna beauty.
Please welcome Lisa Renna, everybody.
(clapping and cheering)
(smooth jazzy music)
- Thank you!
Hello, everybody!
Oh my gosh, this is so fun, Hi Rainn?
- I love, have y'all met before?
- Hi Lisa.
- I don't think we've ever met, have we?
I don't think so.
- Oh, we have.
- [Lisa] We have?
When?
- We have on some red carpet.
Yeah, on some red carpet.
I think you interviewed me once.
- [Lisa] Oh, yes.
- I remember meeting you.
- Yes.
- [Rainn] And being struck
by your magnificence.
- Oh my God, I
how sweet is that?
- I'm struck by you're out there
and now those pants are fire!
- These pants are fabulous.
I've been waiting to be able to wear them.
So I'm so glad,
that I could debut them on
"The Kelly Clarkson Show."
(laughter)
- You're like, "I've been
stuck in sweats in my house."
- Come on, are we not excited?
And look, we both have silver hoops.
- We do, actually I didn't
even know Candice put them in,
but yes, they're silver (laughs)
- They're silver, Kelly.
- Yes.
So wait, Rainn and I
were just talking about
impulsive online purchases.
So, have you ever fallen,
did, or did you fall into
the trap during quarantine?
And have you ever thought about
purchasing a human brain replica?
(laughter)
- Well, actually, no, I've never.
Oh, is that your human brain?
- [Kelly] And he's petting it!
- [Lisa] Okay, well.
- [Kelly] Rainn's wife is now
my favorite human on the planet.
- [Lisa] So that was
a gift from your wife?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Lisa] Wow.
- [Kelly] No, that's a
gift from him to her.
- This is for my wife.
- Oh that is for your wife?
- Yeah, its from him to her.
- God bless your wife.
(laughter)
- No, she asked for it.
She was like, "Man,
- Stop!
- I want a brain" and I was like,
"This is the greatest wife."
You have the greatest wife.
- [Lisa] Wow.
- She's my favorite human.
- I am telling you I
got treated very special
for giving her this gift.
- Yeah, you did.
- Okay, I'm really impressed.
- [Kelly] Extra snuggles.
- I love that, but I don't want a brain.
No, I definitely don't.
Of course I've had many impulse purchases.
- Yeah.
- [Lisa] Of course.
During COVID I bought a
print, two prints of pills.
So, what?
Yes, I know it sounds crazy.
They are literal, it's a pill.
And, Kylie Jenner has them on her wall.
I saw a picture and I thought,
"Well, that's kind of fabulous."
On our show, "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills"
I debuted my pill bag.
I carry a pill bag and I
always have in a Ziploc bag,
since I've had kids,
just so I have--
- I think my half
sister does that.
She's like a walking pharmacy.
- I am a walking pharmacy.
- Just in case
something happens.
- Yes!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Exactly.
So, I thought it might
be cute to have pills
on our wall in our movie room.
(laughter)
Right, doesn't everybody want
pills on their wall in their movie room?
I don't know.
- I think it's awesome.
- I do too.
- I love that's a great impulsive buy.
It's not as, It's not
as cool as the brain.
I'm gonna give you points for that.
- It's certainly different than--
- Oh my God, I just called you Dwight.
That really just happened.
(laughter)
- I wanna know about your movie room.
- It's not that's special, actually.
You just build it, you just
get a big, huge couch for the
you know, 'cause I've
got, I have teenagers.
So we got this big huge couch
that literally 10 people could be on, 12,
and then you get a big, huge TV,
the biggest TV you can buy.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and movie room, boom!
- And you have dark shades,
and I have a popcorn machine
and I have candy.
- And pills.
And that's all you need.
(laughter)
- I love.
- [Lisa] It's really not that hard.